So far, all of our output
values and variables
have been single numbers.
You can also create more
advanced data structures in R
like vectors and data frames.
A vector is a series of
numbers or characters
stored as the same object.
You can create a vector in R
using the c function, which
stands for combine.
In your R console, type
c(2,3,5,8,13) and hit Enter.
This creates a vector of
five numbers all stored
as the same object.
To learn more
about vectors in R,
let's enter some data into R
about the life expectancies
in different countries.
We'll first create a vector
of country names called
Country using the c function.
We'll put each
country name in quotes
since we are typing
characters not numbers.
So in your R
console, type Country
equals and then c for the
combine function, parentheses
and then "Brazil", "China",
"India", "Switzerland",
and then "USA".
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
Now, let's create
a second vector.
This time with the
life expectancies
of these five countries
in the same order
that we entered
the country names.
We'll call this one
LifeExpectancy =
c(74,76,65,83,79) and hit Enter.
Now if you take a look at both
Country and LifeExpectancy,
you can see that Country
has five character values
and LifeExpectancy has
five numerical values.
A word of warning--
you shouldn't
try to combine characters and
numbers in the same vector.
R only allows one data
type in each vector
so all of the numbers will
be converted to characters.
This is bad because
it won't allow
us to do any numerical
calculations with the numbers,
like compute the mean.
If you want to display
an element of a vector,
use square brackets.
For example, we could type
CountryCountry[1] to get the first
element of the Country
vector, Brazil.
Or we could type
LifeExpectancyLifeExpectancy[3] to get
the third element of
LifeExpectancy, 65,
corresponding to India.
Another nice function
to create vectors in R
is the seq function which
creates a sequence of numbers.
Try typing seq(0,100,2).
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This gives a sequence of
numbers from 0 to 100,
starting at zero, the first
argument to the seq function,
ending at 100, the second
and the numbers are
in increments of two,
the third argument
to the seq function.
This can be useful
if you want to create
a unique identifier
for observations.
Now, let's combine
our vectors into what
we call a data frame in R.
This will be an important data
structure for us
because all of the data
files we'll work
with in this course
will be loaded as data frames.
Additionally, many algorithms
in R require all of the data
to be in a single object
like a data frame.
We'll call our data
frame CountryData
and then use the
data.frame function
to combine Country
and LifeExpectancy.
So after typing
CountryData = data.frame,
in parentheses type Country
comma LifeExpectancy.
Then close the
parentheses and hit Enter.
Let's take a look at CountryData
by typing CountryData
and hitting Enter.
It has two columns,
our variables,
and five rows, our observations.
It's similar to how
you might organize data
in a spreadsheet
software like Excel.
Let's say we now want to add
another variable to our data
frame-- the population in
thousands of each country.
We can do this by
using a dollar sign
to link the new data
into the data frame.
So we'll type the name of
our data frame, CountryData,
and then a dollar sign
followed by the name
of the new variable we
want to add, Population.
Then we'll set this equal
to c, and in parentheses
the population in
thousands of each country.
So 199000, 1390000,
1240000, 7997, and 318000.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
Now if you take a
look at CountryData
you should see that we have
a third column, Population.
We'll use this dollar
sign notation a lot
and we'll talk about it
more later in this lecture.
Note that we had to give
the population values
in the correct order.
R will just combine the vectors
in the order they're typed.
Now, suppose we want to add two
new observations for Australia
and Greece.
We first need to create
new Country, LifeExpectancy
and Population vectors.
So we will now set
Country equal to the names
of the new countries,
Australia and Greece.
We'll set LifeExpectancy equal
to the new life expectancies,
82 and 81, and we'll
call Population
a vector of the populations
of these countries 23050
and 11125.
Then we can create
a new data frame.
We'll call this one
NewCountryData and we'll set it
equal to data.frame(Country,
LifeExpectancy, Population).
Note that we combined
three vectors here
with the data.frame function.
If we take a look
at NewCountryData,
we can see that it's very
similar to CountryData.
Lastly, let's combine
CountryData and NewCountryData
with the rbind
function which combines
data frames by
stacking the rows.
We'll call this new data
frame AllCountryData
and we'll use the rbind
function to combine
CountryData, and NewCountryData.
If we take a look
at AllCountryData
we can see that it has the
three variables from before
and all seven observations.
The functions we've
used in this video
have allowed us to
create data structures
and modify data structures
in R. But most of the time
you'll be reading in data
from an external file, which
we'll do in the next video.